look there's a formula for everything in
life there's a formula for success and
there's a formula for failure it is a
day after Thanksgiving it's 8 o'clock in
the morning today it's Friday yes it was
Thanksgiving and I'm at work writing at
the office and I noticed something at
the parking lot when you're here at 8
o'clock in our parking lot you can't
find a single spot to park it reserved
is obviously taken but you can't find a
single spot to park and I want to show
you something I'm back there Park you
see a few cars now watch this this row
you don't see a single car part look
I'll go even further you don't see why
car
oh there's one car all the way in the
back it's a PT Cruiser all the way in
the back now walk here with me look at
this me take the plates away so hey you
know why do you think some people become
wealthy and successful did they get
lucky did they get lucky no look at this
you don't understand I wish I could have
a camera here to show you what this
looks like on any given day on any given
day
look this is purely a validation look
look look oh my gosh look all those
spots you will not find a single spot
open look boom look at that let's see
how many people are open here you'll see
one car all the way in the back you see
white car back did you see it
I don't know if you see it or not
there's a formula for everything
yesterday was Thanksgiving I hope you
had a good one we did we had a great
time we had family and friends over we
had a phenomenal time you know what
society tells everybody to do today the
after Thanksgiving is to go to the lines
and stand outside for Black Friday cuz
something's gonna be on sale oh my gosh
it's gonna be on sale men if people put
the same exact effort into work their
butts off they would never care about a
sale it wouldn't even be a reason to
have a sell but Society tells us
wake up Black Friday great marketing
gimmick wake up go out there you're
going to be able to buy something that's
$300 for only $100 why not go work on
and make that additional $200
look I remember when I had a
nine-to-five I cleared my one out of
nine to five in our war dead man alleys
or I had another job there are two
different types of nine of fibers are
1092 fibers that come to work
look even the building has shut it down
we're open today we're working today
there are people who work 9:00 to 5:00
who are people who work 9:00 to 5:00 who
do the following you know the people
that show up at 8:59
and leave at 501 those people will never
be entrepreneurs they will never be
entrepreneurs okay I came on base I
didn't get paid hourly I think if it was
alone whatever I came on days I didn't
get paid hourly or overtime never once
in my career has a company paid me
overtime never once not a single time
there's Abigail you'll say hi she's
working the day after Thanksgiving can I
show you this are you guys really
working the day after Thanksgiving
aren't you supposed to be off hanging
out today I love it
crazy people there you go girl all right
so let's go over here they have a choice
they can put a day off we won't
down back there that sounds perfect
what should you get on sounds perfect I
was pressing Rumble he's rebellious he
chose to work at the after is that
Dennis back there Dennis how you doing
buddy
don't go gives a shot I'm in high dunes
II know good right y'all I'd work nine
to five you never see me leave at five
it just wouldn't work that way why for
what if I plan on only staying at the
position I want then yes then I'll work
nine to five then that would be my
schedule if that's what I'm doing but no
it doesn't work that way try a family in
town I stayed a little longer and I came
to the office at 8:00 a.m. and people
are still working here today and if
you're watching this and you're running
around trying to get something on sale
at Best Buy Walmart or whatever it is
and you don't like this video change it
if you don't like this video it's
because you're part of that group look
there comes a time where you look new
yours is only a month away we got it we
have five more weeks away to make some
serious decision on what life's going to
look like in 2017 I'm very clear on what
I want to do I got very clear what I
want to do purpose with my life I wasn't
always this focused I wasn't always this
determined I am very very clear on what
I want my life to look like and why I'm
doing what I'm doing my challenge to you
is don't let society dictate how you
ought to work if society tells us you
ought to work 9:00 to 5:00 you work 5:00
to 9:00 yes 5:00 to 9:00 oh my gosh I
can't believe Patrick's saying this at a
debate the other day person told me I
said you know this whole thing about
rich people work harder and all this
other stuff I work hard too I said
really tell me how hard you work tell me
how hard you work and how often you do
it do you work on these days do you work
on Memorial Day Labor Day you take those
four-day week of course
you're supposed to do no no no that's
what society tells you to do that's not
what you're supposed to do yes I took
yesterday off the afternoon and the
evening and I spend with my family I
worked in the morning and I spent on my
family had a great time I'm gonna take
Christmas off and then I'm gonna have a
week that whilst at a resort not a
resort the biggest private castle you
can rent in America Oheka in December
I'm renting it for the entire week I
rented the entire price 32 rooms we're
taking 32 people there to mentor them
for five days yes we're doing that now
that's the stuff that I get excited
about 150 million dollar property that's
exciting that's exciting to me so look
if you made it already this far in this
video and you're just waking up or
you're one of the people that your
parking lot is empty because you didn't
drive into work today
adjust life is expensive
kids are expensive marriage is expensive
getting older is expensive health is
expensive staying healthy is expensive
being keno being able to advance in life
requires effort dedication when no one
sees you doing what you do on a daily
basis and then five ten years later when
you win big you know what's the most
annoying comment everyone's going to
make to you or we always knew you were
gonna make it but no one knows what you
did when the parking lot was empty you
were the only one I work so if you're
the only one I work today I just want to
tell you you have decided to make your
own Black Friday any given date that you
choose it to make your Black Friday
because you don't care what a price is
going to cause you're willing to pay the
full price you don't want to buy stuff
for sale
it's my message to you and guess what
happy Thanksgiving to everybody may 2017
be the greatest year of your life
because you made a decision to change
five weeks before the end of the year